uh so talk about uh
the album slash film
so what is exactly the first of all how
long did it take you to record because
I'm sure are you recording at home
you're going to the studio like no I'm
going to the studio I never have a
studio in my house
um
I'm going to the studio took like seven
months right and it's basically like
because it's called chapters of the
trenches right and I'm just walking you
through like everything that happened in
the trenches not everything but some of
the stuff that happened every day what
are some of the chapters I saw one was
like robbery you got robbery yeah you
got Jay Antoine about two two guys in
the trenches Who coming up you know what
I'm saying you got Miss Evans about a
fine ass teacher and these young
students just trying to [ __ ] her yeah
you got um tears and tone by the uncle
and a nephew neph trying to get put on
you know yeah so that they battling that
um
yeah Shakespeare classic a little Hood
love story but the inside though he dies
both they die both of them end up living
eternally you know what I mean in heaven
uh
any scamming records
I ain't got no scamming records I ain't
no scammer though
but you oh yeah if you if you don't know
about it then why would you make a song
about it yeah I don't know matter of
fact I could try though I could I can I
know what's going on so I can I can kind
of do it yeah oh I could talk about how
[ __ ] blew all that money all that EDD
I can talk about things blew all that
money
and now they will do whatever that ppos
[ __ ] ran out huh all that [ __ ] yeah I
knew so many people were just eating
during the pandemic I was like I don't I
had so many people trying to convince me
like bro he's I'm like bro ain't nothing
that easy
anybody try to convince you some money's
that easy I'm like you know what was
that bait from the fence it might have
been because they're arresting everybody
yeah they are definitely arresting
everybody there's a uh the song about
everything's on record and people
snitching yeah well you know what it is
it's like
allegedly there might have been people
that were paying homeless people for
their IDs and their social security
cards
and then getting their check sent
somewhere yeah that's a fact you know in
theory not the worst idea still a paper
trail still a paper trail because whose
address is it going to exactly 100
percent
100 was Miss Evans uh inspired by a real
teacher that you were trying to [ __ ]
when you were a kid
um no
um that story came from my from my
fiance okay and I'm in her hometown a
teacher had got like 20 something years
where's she from Saginaw Michigan okay
Saginaw is not too far from Detroit
right like an hour and a half yeah yeah
and um she was like you should make a
song about that and she gave me the idea
and I'm like damn you're right that's
tight you know and everybody can relate
to it